[Música]
eu amo contar histórias e eu sou
daquelas que sei todas as datas de todos
os eventos de core e hoje vou começar
contando com você conta pra vocês três
dessas datas dia 18 de maio de 2017 eu
estava tirando férias realizando um
sonho antigo de conhecer nova york
eu passei na frente da escola de
negócios da new york university e gravar
um vídeo pra minha mãe falando com o
incrível inimaginável seria se um dia eu
tivesse privilégio de estar lá com uma
aluna dia 20 de maio de 2018 eu estava
segurando a minha carteirinha de aluna
começando meu primeiro módulo do
mestrado em gerenciamento de riscos daí
maio dia 24 de maio de 2019
eu estava de beca com meu filho a minha
mãe melhor amiga passando por um último
dos eventos da minha formatura foi um
alívio uma alegria enorme
foi uma honra estar lá mas eu gostaria
que hoje dizer pra vocês que toda vez
que eu conto essa história e tantas
outras
eu recebi uma reação freqüente uma
pergunta que me incomoda
como é que você dá conta de tudo
na verdade eu sei que as pessoas queriam
mesmo me perguntar mas ela tem vergonha
como você trabalha tanto e cuida do seu
filho você viaja tanto você não sente
saudades dele
você não se sente culpada ea minha
resposta para a primeira pergunta é eu
não dou conta de tudo para buscar em
todos os dias eu procurasse no eu perco
prazos do pizza pro meu filho de jantar
eu realmente me sinto cansada sem
paciência e eu me sinto sozinha mas eu
sei que eu não sou a única que eu queria
realmente aqui chamar a atenção para que
a gente pare com a supervalorização da
perfeição
nenhuma profissional
mãe é uma super mulher que todas nós
tivemos nossas grandes e pequenas
vitórias grandes e pequenas derrotas e
todas nós temos que nos habituar de algo
todos os dias para simplesmente
continuar indo então pra ser voz e dar
voz a isso
hoje vou compartilhar três conselhos que
lhe foram relatados nos livros que eu li
nas palestras que eu assistir e
principalmente no amor e na dor
o primeiro deles o conselho número 1
corra riscos e divirta se
muitos pesquisadores falam ao longo dos
anos que homens são mais tomadores de
risco enquanto as mulheres são mais
avessas ao risco no começo dos anos 2000
cerca de r alguns pesquisadores
pesquisaram aí cerca de 150 artigos
sobre esse tema e em escritos entre o
ano os anos de 1967 e 1997 chegaram e
sata mesma conclusão seja por fatores
psicológicos biológicos ou pura
estereótipo estudos ainda mais recentes
afirmam que sob stress homens são ainda
mais tomadores de risco mulheres ainda
menos
e pra correr riscos a gente precisa
aprender um com várias coisas a gente
precisa ter parceiros aliados torcedores
verdadeiros ter uma rede de apoio
aprender de verdade a delegar para
correr riscos a gente não pode parar de
dançar antes da música terminar a gente
tem que criar possibilidades
oportunidades de se permitir eu peça que
ela aquele aumento que você merece
mude de cidade de emprego de vida e
claro ria
divirta-se conselho número dois coletes
suas datas e construa sua história
entre aquelas três primeiras datas que
eu citei tiveram tantas outras que
descrevem tão bem o que eu sou e para
onde eu vou
collet elas todos os dias nas suas vidas
as pequenas vitórias as pequenas falhas
os pequenos milagres dia 30 em abril de
descobrimos que o tumor cerebral que o
meu pai enfrentou em 2012 havia voltado
maior e mais agressivo
eu me enche de tristeza mas me enche de
otimismo dia 19 de janeiro de 2018 eu
recebi o diagnóstico de uma doença
auto-imune eu descobri que as dores e os
inchaços das minhas articulações tinha
um nome que o meu cansaço tinha um preço
e nesse dia eu postei uma foto de
coxinha nas redes sociais
dia 23 de abril de 2018 então nem meu
pai pela última vez no dia 29 ele se foi
e horas depois no mesmo dia
nasceu seu terceiro neto meu sobrinho
pedro pra mostrar pra gente que a vida é
cercada de ciclos cercada de milagres
dia 26 de junho de 2018 eu busquei meu
filho na escola ele estava um pouco
febril espaço no mercado e fazendo as
compras
ele leu comigo pela primeira vez caixa'
ali escrito caixa é a mamãe de 11 de
agosto de 2018 a empresa que o trabalho
sendo uma revista de grande circulação
eu comprei a revista
deixei meu filho achar o artigo e
reconheceu o escritório orgulho dele do
meu trabalho me fez chorar chorar como
eu choro
o tempo todo pra todas as coisas em
qualquer lugar e eu me fiz um propósito
de parar de ter vergonha disso
o que me leva o conselho número 3 abraço
imperfeição pra gente ter coragem de
evoluir de verdade a coragem dia evoluir
é preciso abraçar nossas imperfeições as
nossas vulnerabilidades
só que entende suas falhas que entende o
que é ser vulnerável consegue ser
verdadeiramente você
a autora benê brown escreveu certa vez
se lê sempre me toca escrever nossa
própria história pode ser difícil mas
não é tão duro quanto passar a vida
fugindo dela aceitar as nossas
vulnerabilidades é arriscado mas não é
tão perigoso quanto desistir do amor do
pertencimento e da alegria que por outro
lado são as experiências que nos deixam
mais vulneráveis
somente quando tivermos coragem
suficiente para explorar a escuridão
descobriremos o poder infinito da nossa
luz
portanto corra riscos e evita cinco
colegas suas datas e construa sua
história a praça imperfeição e parta
para a ação
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]